[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Vậy hãy mở bài tập của bạn
đây. >> Brian Holt: Một cái gì đó
khác mà gấu đề cập đến. >> Brian Holt: Tôi đã viết một chút
công cụ trực quan hóa cho bạn, vì vậy, >> Brian Holt: Nếu
bạn nhìn xuống đây, bạn sẽ thấy đây là câu trả lời
sẽ như thế nào. >> Brian Holt: Nó được gọi là vòng lặp bong bóng,
cuz nhìn vào cái này 1, phải không?
Bạn có thể thấy 1 loại bong bóng này lên đến đầu.
Đó là lý do tại sao nó trông,
mọi thứ có xu hướng nổi lên. >> Brian Holt: Và đó là lý do tại sao nó được gọi là
vòng lặp bong bóng, hoặc đúng hơn là sắp xếp bong bóng. >> Brian Holt: Được rồi,
vì vậy hãy vào đây để tập thể dục. >> Brian Holt: [COUGH] Vậy
một lần nữa, nếu bạn muốn tạm ngừng chạy thử nghiệm,
chỉ cần xuống dưới đây và nói xdescribe.
Tôi thực sự khuyên bạn điều đó bởi vì khi bạn bắt đầu viết những vòng lặp này,
you're gonna get a infinite loop, which is the ugly cousin of the infinite
recursion. >> Brian Holt: Actually,
they're kinda both equally ugly.
Both of them are gonna make your browser tab crash, so don't.
I have here a recap of how bubble sort works.
It's exactly what I just described to you. >> Brian Holt: And
then there is the optional visualization helper.
You don't have to use this, your unit test will still pass without it.
But if you want to, at the beginning of your inner loop, call snapshot.
Snapshot with whatever your array is, just passing the whole array.
And if you do that,
you'll get the visualization tool at the bottom just working for free, hopefully.
But yeah, just call it every single time, it'll do all the deduplication for you.